України
айварас абромавічус міністр абромавічус
слив немає прибираючи
дуже ризику та вид криту заявок дзвін
на власні очі включаю свою роботу я до
адміністрації президента так і
конкретного депутата президентський вигляд
фракції та кажучи кононенко астані розпочато
активно лобі його у своїх людей на
ключові сади в міністерстві
тоді шпет спадкоємство я можу
розглядати такі дії можна
розряд і такі дикий крик напливу праворуч
Авто ви контроль зафарбовуємо і
потоками
задати спадкоємство ми особливо його нак
нафтогаз то оборонну промисловість гирлом і
я йду бодай проти ти в такі системі
ні я ні моя куманда напоготові слабкувато
прикриттям для помилування старих та
створ не нових схем на користь затишних
політичних the business or актив
політичних та бізнес гравців сам
кононенко вид замовлення вже вид христу вся
назвав заяви міністра качину
експерти тиснемо на поводу у тебе на році ще
за втомиться і ворог у тих же інших листів
міністр інфраструктури високо по садовій
які д через тест на свої відомства я
хочу обгризені ріо хватом і знайти факти
імідж України буду достатньо земного
поки що заяву наробити intel дефектами
зуя плату он від далеким tomizu я
президента і там у всіх будинки області що
будуть роботи через -2 що будуть відразу
он і також будуть милою мітингу ось
тягнете на сьогодні корупційного за
собою майже одну для логіки міс
політично ці душі був лійка проблема з
проблема для супер і ось ця ціна справа
проблем національної bespoke для України
реакції захисних політики не забиралася
я низько після у надзвичайно wrap це америці
про прилюдне стильно заяву
дикі вислала розчарування адже ставку
та міністра закривала українську владу
100 ват і інтереси народу вищі
адже своїх експерт вона не вимикаєте
париж та не видно song його та за ходом їх
і довіряти міністрові та покладам на нього
були кінодив міністр
мій душ гарну репутацію захисних
партнерів series red
після вперед донорських організацій
vintage там зибрів гарну команду
буде всім про міністерство і я думаю що
за раз багата будуть людей у
міністерствах та
міжнародному валютному фонді світовому
банк світловому банки і так далі які
думатимуть про скін ви зараз будемо
потряс право українському уряду
як цих людей більше буду якщо таких
вчених заяв закіні донори вже на
закривати
дуже на корупції в Україні і ви магате
мати легальних змін вид влади піцу мови
увійти експерти